Olivia under fire on The Bachelor women
tell all specials that was after you
trash talked me so you need already
having her Olivia and Amanda faced off
over Olivia's infamous comparison
she said Amanda reminded her of the show
Teen Mom feel like it's an episode of
Teen Mom that I watch ring set that was
not a very nice thing to say
did you not talk about me my kids when I
that got any guys should be running the
other way
from somebody with kids I got the pair's
reactions to the taping right after it
all went down like it was pretty awful I
am also proud that you know I stood up
and apologized and that it was hard to
do because I knew I was meant to I
messed up so moment I would kind of
erase that one she's just one of those
people I just don't really understand it
I don't click with and that's okay and
you're not gonna click with everybody
you know what I mean so but I do
appreciate her apology and I think that
she did try hard to explain herself
whether we all understood it or not I
knew she made an effort